Guten morgen tim bei mir schon ja.
Netz politik nummer dreihundertsiebzehn vom fünfzehnten oktober zweitausendneunzehn und die geneigten hörerinnen und hörer wenn sie jetzt fragen was wir gleich nach einem tag schon wieder eine sendung was bei euch los.
Das haben wir noch nie gemacht.
Sicher oder wenn wir jetzt gar nicht so sicher ich glaube so ab und zu reichen wir dann doch mal auch ein spezial rein,
wenn es denn die stunde schlägt und,
heute ist mal wieder so ein tag wo wir uns mal auf was ganz anderes fokussieren wollten was aber trotzdem unserer meinung nach so ein bisschen hier ins profil passt und auf jeden fall der erzählung,
konkret wollen wir heute über eine organisation berichten mit dem namen kakadus und dazu haben wir auch noch einen gast mit an bord nämlich den selbst bastian niemann hallo servus.
Ja äh sepp was ist was ist kakadus in einem satz.
Einsatz äh dann würde ich sagen cactus ist eine humanitäre hilfsorganisation ganz knapp und kurz aus.
Genau und darum soll es gehen und das ganze kriegt gerade etwas aktualität durch die sich überschlagen vorfälle in der türkei,
dort seid ihr mit einem team,
unterwegs im einsatz um dort vor ort leute zu helfen dass jetzt auch nicht erst seit kurzem sondern schon seit längerem ihr habt so ein längeres engagement insbesondere in der syrischen region,
und ihr seid im prinzip so 'ne eigene ego aber halt so ein bisschen anders als die anderen videos das kann man glaub ich so ganz gut sagen.
Ja ich glaube schon hier.
Dann erzähl uns doch mal,
wie das anfängt also was seit wann gibt es carlos wofür steht auch der name das mir bisher noch gar nicht gelungen außer unserem griechischen volumen maß hab ich da keine richtige erklärung finden können.
Du hast das ja alles angestoßen wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja genau also
der hintergrund ist der ich komme ein bisschen aus dem bereich ähm hab immer neben studium bin ich rettungsdienst gefahren äh schon seit dem zivildienst und hab da auch den beruf dann gelernt und habe bei bei vielen katastrophen gearbeitet.
Christine.
Genau und das war so das womit ich mir mein studium finanziert habe und deswegen hatte ich aber immer so einen so einen
relativ früh nach dem zivildienst beim ersten internationalen katastrophen für organisationen tätig fand es aber,
ich fand es arbeiten unfassbar gut und fand aber viele organisationen für dich unterwegs war,
wie seine fragwürdig ist blöd sondern einfach dass das das feeling mit denen zu arbeiten das passte nicht zu der sucht kultur aus der vielleicht selber kam.
Wann ich cool genug oder zu locker oder das kann man das zusammen.
Na tatsächlich gibt's so ne also.
Hilfsorganisation so aus den aus den äh aus der sogenannten globalen norden die haben ja ganz oft so ein so ein so ein ding ne wir gehen irgendwohin
wir helfen da kurz hauen wieder ab stehen so ein bisschen über die situation das fand ich immer sehr unangenehm.
Weil ich bin damals da reingerutscht in diesem bereich über einen hurricane in nicaragua wo ich wirklich drei vier tage später zufällig fast schon gelandet bin weil der flug forschung gebucht war und
das war faszinierend fand mit leuten,
also auf augenhöhe zu gucken wie kann man sich tatsächlich gegenseitig unterstützen und fand das sehr unangenehm wenn man die aus kam ne mit dem,
teure gemieteten autos kurz der projekte gemacht haben aber auch nach den projekten eigentlich nichts mehr geblieben ist.
Wenn sie verzogen haben dazu ist es so ein ding viele hilfsorganisationen ziehen einen ganz eigenen schlag menschen an,
wir haben vielleicht auch so bock auf dieses mit so uniform und bock auf dieses bisschen testosteron und ich habe neben dieser arbeit im rettungsdienst und bei der organisation,
viel in so einem kulturellen bereich gab es so festivals organisieren selber ins zentrum mitgearbeitet und dachte immer dass wir so toll wenn man manchmal den schlag mensch mit dem man sich so wohl fühlt,
den in diesen arbeitsbereich quasi transferieren könnte.
Ich hab dann irgendwann das hätte ich gesagt ach leute das mal gucken das was wir hier machen wie zum beispiel ein festival auf der grünen wiese aufstellen,
und eine stadt für sechzig siebzigtausend menschen innerhalb von wenigen tagen aus dem boden stampfen und auch wieder abbauen das sind ja genau die kompetenzen,
die man eigentlich so katastrophen gebiet braucht das alles beine strom wasser sanitär telekommunikation.
Leute koordinieren.
Bauen.
Das war so ein bisschen wo ich dachte dass da stecken so viele kompetenzen bei leuten die für sich vielleicht noch nie im kopf hatten das obere katastrophe einsetzen zu können,
dass sie irgendwann war nach dem festival so bisschen in der.
In der ausnüchterungszelle phase da saßen und ich meinte auch kommen wollt was sie mal versuchen und so ist karlos eigentlich dann zweitausendvierzehn entstanden.
Warum der name.
Den.
Ihr hattet auch mehrere namen ist es.
Ja tatsächlich war das so,
wir haben tatsächlich einen ein verein übernommen den schon gab der sich auflösen wollte der hieß wind sehen raus um berliner haus projekt umfeld sind eigentlich im alternative energien.
Oder bausätze für alternative energie.
Was für sie windräder geschichten und die waren aber kurz davor zu sagen ach das wir machen eh nichts mehr wir lösen das jetzt auf und haben uns quasi,
angeboten durch eintreten in den verein den zu übernehmen.
Sondern einfach ein.
So ist es ne als andere mitglieder es dauert ja so ein bisschen das so zu übernehmen aber dann tatsächlich auf dem sehr legalen weg diesen verein einfach nicht sterben zu lassen und dann haben wir gesagt gut wir machen jetzt etwas anderes wir haben den vereins,
zweck auch quasi dann per per mitgliederentscheid auf die matte hilfe um umgeswitcht und dann war auch klar wir brauchen einen neuen namen,
und haben den im endeffekt tatsächlich durch äh so ein so ein sonst so 'n semester arbeit im kommunikationsdesign an der hochschule.
Quasi entwickeln lassen also das war so professorin angebot nummer studis die könnten euch mal beim branding helfen und es war ganz spannend damals waren relativ neu im spiel.
Und carlos ist dann entstanden bei denen.
Zwei bedeutung das eine ist tatsächlich wenn du es mit einem doppel a und,
schreibt und cardio dann ist es lateinische für die liste.
Und die liste ist nämlich entscheiden pflanze ist aber auch ne stachel leg unbequem,
passt nicht so richtig ne das bild der schönen pflanze und wächst aber vor allem aus gibt's eine medizinische display die wächst in nordsyrien da unsere ersten einsatzgebiete waren und dann dachten wir münchen ist so 'ne schöne geschichte kann man erzählen
bisschen geglättet von der optik deswegen pokal vereinzelt und dass er weg und dann haben wir jetzt festgestellt was du gerade schon meintest,
dass das auch einen alte römische maß für wein ist.
Und dann dachten wir in der doppel bedeutung ist eigentlich total super weil mit der diesel passenderweise das ganze schön erzählen aber für unseren hintergrund dass wir eigentlich aus dem festival bereich mal kam passt das mit dem wein dann irgendwie dann auch ganz gut.
So sind wir bei dem namen dann quasi geblieben.
So jetzt ist das ganze in berlin basiert so und ihr habt euch,
auch ein ort geschaffen der dann wiederum ganz gut hier in unserer interessen kern interessen spektrum reinpasst weil ihr habt jetzt nicht nur so ein büro oder so sondern ihr kennt das ja selber auch make-up peace.
Genau.
Was was was ist da was was findet der statt.
Wir nennen es quasi bons make-up space ähm und es ist nicht so make-up space wie,
man normalerweise make-up space kennt dass man da hingehen kann vielleicht in der produktidee
betreut wird und für sich quasi dann sozusagen sein für dein startup vielleicht ein prototypen entwickelt sondern wir haben gesagt wer bei uns was machen möchte ist herzlich willkommen aber,
es geht bei uns eine open source und es muss sich um eine humanitäre oder ökologische problematik handeln wofür man quasi lösungsansätze entwickeln möchte.
Und wir hatten diese werkstatt wir haben damals auch unser erstes großprojekt gebaut mobiles krankenhaus für nordsyrien,
und als das fertig war und auf den weg gebracht war haben wir gedacht mensch
die werkstatt die ist so toll die so zentral gelegen äh es gab so viel zuspruch bei diesen bau prozess dass wir belegt haben,
so viele dinge indem man eigentlich basteln müsste das sind doch versuchen diese werkstatt zu behalten
und die haben jetzt stück für stück immer besser ausgestattet viel metalltechnik,
schweißen plasma schneiden sowas in die richtung wir haben riesige c fräse viel holz bereich auch bisschen elektrotechnik und das wächst immer so ein bisschen weiter das meer sachen dazu kommen und.
Genau gibt einen offenen tag die woche das wirklich so open space ist an den anderen tagen muss man mal gucken wer sich ab spricht.
Oh wir arbeiten jetzt an verschiedenen projekten und produkten sage ich mal so ganz aktuell haben wir zum beispiel bauen wir eine müll verbrenner.
Also mal viel nicht so richtig bewusst medizinischer müll in katastrophen gebieten den kann man nicht einfach in die gegend schmeißen machen leute,
meistens so weil es keine lösung gibt damit sich dadurch nicht infektionen und solchen und ähnliches ausbreiten können muss man denn eigentlich effektiv verbrennen da gibt's vorgaben von der who wie heißt das sein muss,
und so ein produkt gibt es auf dem markt einfach nicht weil der markt so klein ist dass ich keine firma interessiert so eine müllverbrennung zu entwickeln der diese maßstäben entspricht,
und das sind dann genau nummern wo wir sagen okay wir haben kein gewinn interesse wir wollen nicht das problem lösen genau das kann man halt hier machen.
Also du schildert das so als wäre das irgendwie so also du erzählst also fast als wäre das was völlig normales sich also ist für dich aber offenbar auch,
diese werkstatt ist jetzt wirklich ein beeindruckendes ding also man erkennt natürlich den die
die festival kultur erkennt man da drin weil ihr eben immer auch direkt auf
ernst zu nehmendes werkzeug setzen also das ich glaube irgendwie so 'n so 'n klassischen drei d drucker irgend so einen kleinen drei-d-druck hatte man im sonstigen makers space findet der wenn ihr den habt dann sieht man den in dieser riesigen halle nicht.
Ganzer essbaren bogen mit mit hoch regalen also das ist wirklich ein sehr rustikaler makers bis in dem große sachen gebaut werden das ist ja gerade gesagt das mobile krankenhaus
jetzt nicht irgendwie so dass man sagt wir bauen uns also offenbar schon ich finde wirklich nachhaltig seit jahren von geflasht das.
Man hört ja viel so gerade jetzt nichts gegen festivals auf festivals kommt viele gute ideen ne
nicht alle guten ideen die auf festivals kommen werden dann auch zu ende geführt und,
also gehörte so ja hier die die gründen jetzt eine.
Organisation,
und bauen sich ein mobiles krankenhaus wo ich ausgedachte,
hui vielleicht wird das aber vielleicht nichts liebe kinder ne und,
das irgendwie so in dieser in diesem ausmaß hochzuziehen es ist schon echt 'ne ziemlich krasse nummer.
Wir haben das zwischendurch auch ganz oft gedacht ne dass das vielleicht nichts wird also wir sind auch mehrmals tatsächlich also würde ich sagen er wege gegangen aber die pläne sind immer groß tatsächlich das ist oder,
hat auch viel damit zu tun vielleicht welche leute am anfang zusammengefunden haben dass man immer denkt irgendwie nichts ist unmöglich ich habe zum beispiel ich habe gar keine metallbauer erfahrung im hintergrund aus ausbildung ich hab das da im mega-park gelernt
ich hab vorher gedacht das kann doch nicht so schwer sein so ein auto zu schmeißen.
Und so nimmt man sich vielleicht auch aufgaben die dann doch größer sind als man vorher gedacht hat es ist schon durchaus so dass dass das schon zwei dreimal auch.
Ein bisschen gescheitert ist.
Ja so ne die mühen der ebenen ne also das ist schon.
Ja ich sage mal dreihundert prozent anstreben hundertfünfzig prozent erreichen also man muss sich ja irgendwie auch.
Reicht dann ist da ganz ganz nachlässig.
Genau.
Na ja also man muss ja dann sage ich denke mal wenn man sich auch zu viel gedanken vorher macht hält man sich am ende eigentlich für kleiner als man letztlich ist so
und die man einfach ein bisschen größenwahnsinnig auch rangeht und so vielleicht auch offensichtliche probleme oder von dem man glaubt dass sie offensichtlich sind,
sich gleich vor allem aufbauen dann hört man halt auch auf seine eigenen fähigkeiten überhaupt richtig zum einsatz zu bringen,
das ist das ding du meintest ihr hättet schon vorher bevor ihr für euch was gemacht habe ein mobiles krankenhaus als auftrag oder.
Das haben wir.
Also damit ging's dann quasi los also ihr habt verein gegründet satzung geändert leider ja jetzt jetzt geht 's los jetzt gehts los,
was war dann euer allererstes bau also womit fing es an also ihr seid nicht gleich irgendwohin gefahren und vater.
Doch tatsächlich und genau das war nämlich das ding ne zweitausendvierzehn war ja so die phase wo dieses dieses projekt roger war diese komische selbst organisierung im norden syriens
unter massiven angriffen des sogenannten islamischen staates stand,
gleichzeitig gab es hier in berlin ein ganz großes interesse was was ist das da was passiert da gerade was das für ein emanzipatorischen des gesellschafts projekt es gab halt also
das wurde zum teil extrem gehypt zum teil natürlich sofort die frage gestellt kann ja gar nicht sein und waren die kurden und kurdinnen war das nicht immer irgendwie so eine statistische geschichte was ist da eigentlich,
und dann gab es in berlin leute gesagt haben wir glauben das ist mega spannend was da passiert und das ist eine solidarisches interessantes gesellschaft projekt wir fahren jetzt mal hin wir machen eine sogenannte fact findling mission,
ging viel darum
dass man das realisten waren dabei und die hatten uns dann angefragt wirklich quasi kurzer vereins gründung und meinten hier ich hab doch mediziner und medizinerin dabei,
könnt ihr nicht zwei leute mitschicken die den medizinischen teil seiner mischen machen also was aussagen können über was sind die probleme da vor ort,
und außerdem sich quasi auch um die um die medizinische versorgung des teams kümmern können weil es war immer ein aktives.
Immer praktisch ein arzt dabei zu haben.
Genau es ist immer nicht dumm ne.
Wir waren in dem moment so größenwahnsinnig vielleicht oder auch einfach vor allem selber interessiert und haben gesagt klar sind zu zweit damit gefahren.
Und dann gesagt das können wir auch als organisation gucken wir uns das an.
Sowas einer von den beiden.
Ich war einer von den beiden genau und dann waren wir in der region und das war.
Ich war ja in vielen äh katastrophen region schon damit so das habe ich auch noch nicht vorher in dem kriegsgebiet.
Und das was man da war erlebt hat das hat uns schon oder mich vor allem so so nachhaltig geflasht.
Das war in dem moment also a dieses gesellschaft projekt dieses emanzipatorischen dieses gleichstellung mann frau,
natürlich gibt's da noch total viele probleme in der region und man kann da nicht innerhalb von einem jahr erwarten dass eine gesellschaft sich komplett redet aber es war sehr faszinierend und teilweise unfassbar deprimieren zu sehen,
das internationale hilfsorganisation da nicht hingegangen wird man wusste nicht so richtig ne was ist das jetzt.
Kurden kurden die wird neues machen wie bewertet man das politisch ganz viele staaten und vor allem natürlich die türkei haben gesagt nein das nicht alles terroristisch,
und deswegen gab es für die region auch nicht wirklich gelder das war der moment wo wir dann da waren und gesehen haben das leid war unfassbar groß das war ein ganz,
mieser blutiger boden kampf wird zwischen eis und den und den kurdischen milizen,
es gab aber eigentlich 'nen gesundheitssystem vor ort das was was dem nicht nicht nicht gewachsen war.
Denn dann wird zuerst gesagt wir mit ausbildungsprogramm gestartet da muss,
in lokalen partnern und partnerin die wir gefunden haben ey wir versuchen euch das.
Als als fachwissen hierher zu bringen was was ihr vielleicht jetzt grade hier nicht habt weil die menschen mit fachwissen geflohen sind oder schon tot am angefangen so so ausbildung zu machen.
Weil wir gesagt haben die strecken von der front.
Zu den krankenhäusern die waren immer so lang dass sehr viele menschen sowohl zivilisten als auch kämpfen auf den strecken gestorben sind da war der erste ansatz zu sagen okay wir müssen die versorgung in diesen ambulanten verbessern.
Mussten aber irgendwann einsehen ähm so ein so ein bildungsprojekte ist auch eine ganz schöne große nummer,
dass es vielleicht zu groß für uns flächendeckend und haben dann gesagt was können wir denn sonst machen gemeinden gut wenn die front zu weit vom krankenhaus weg ist dann muss das krankenhaus halt zu front,
vielleicht bauen wir mal was was fährt und was der dynamischen lage immer hinterher fährt und haben dann auf basis von zwei alte tracks.
Und nem so ein mobiles krankenhaus gebaut mit auf blass zelten wo wir gesagt haben wir können in dieser situation immer der lage quasi folgen egal ob vor oder.
So was gibt es nicht also ich mein es gibt doch krankenwagen was ist der unterschied zwischen einem mobilen krankenhaus und einem krankenwagen.
Ein krankenwagen ist für den transport gemacht da ist.
Mit versorgung in gewisser hinsicht.
Ja aber das ist eine versorgung die ist für 'ne kurze zeit für den transport gedacht ne da kannst du
luft und wasser in die person reinmachen ne da kannst du strom drauf blitzen kammerflimmern hat.
Das kranken fahrzeug ist eigentlich so mensch muss lebend im krankenhaus ankommen das dafür ist das design.
Genau und im krankenhaus ein mobiles heißt dann tatsächlich wenn du den schuss denn die brust bekommen hast dann wird es da definitiv versorgt definitiv was in dem moment also endgültig versorgt,
es wird so versorgt dass man dich danach quasi nur noch irgendwo in den enden,
ja wahrscheinlich ein krankenbett legen muss und phase die nachsorge machen muss also da ist ein kleiner op dabei da sind auf platz zählt wurde op-tisch dabei ist,
dass der chirurgische material dabei du hast viel mehr equipment als in den krankenwagen du hast genau diese ganzen geschichten die leute sind über über über stunden oder ganzen tag bei dir du musst es auch gedanken machen,
na wo könnte ich auch so gehen das zieht viel viel nach.
Das heißt so in der form habt ihr das auch woanders nicht gesehen also sowas hat.
Dort ist was gibt's natürlich
ähm wenn jetzt weiß ich nicht weißt du was in berlin gibt aber in den usa ganz gebräuche liegt dass ich halt große städte mit großen krankenhäusern dass die jetzt sagen mensch findet ding es mal ab fackelt,
dann braucht man trotzdem mobilen op ne oder militär hat sowas und mobiles krankenhaus das sind dann aber immer gleich so zwanzig schuss container.
Oder riesige trucks und kostet immer.
Wirklich so oft millionen level und wir dachten damals gut für roter war gibt kein geld wir machen selber spendensammlung da müssen wir gucken das günstiger zu bauen und haben eins für ich glaub das ganze bau und das equipment das hat nachher hundertfünfzig hundertsechzig tausend euro gekostet,
name die fahrzeuge gebaut sie umgebaut das auf platz zählt gekauft die medikamenten ausstattung und das war natürlich so ein bisschen auf die ebene auch zu sagen wenn es das produkt auf den markt gibt kostbar fünf sechs millionen die haben wir jetzt nicht
dann müssen wir es irgendwie selber machen.
Und wie also,
war blöd zu vergleichen wieder mit der festival kultur
der bauen sich auch viele solche fahrzeuge ehrlicher größe aus zu einem wohnmobil ne und was er dann sehr viel hörst ist dass sie sich denn vorher sehr lange austauschen wie man jetzt da die inneneinrichtung macht irgendwie groß muss jetzt badezimmer sein geht
zu lasten der küche das sind ja alles irgendwie kinder problemchen im vergleich zu meinem baut ein ganzes krankenhaus da rein,
also die planung,
habt ihr da abgeschaut oder hattet ihr hattet ihr einfach genug medizinerin im team die gesagt haben so und so muss das sein und so und so nicht oder habt ihr da auch mit try and error gearbeitet oder.
Ich sag zu allem maja.
Ist definitiv eine mischung gewesen und viel war so dass wir dadurch dass wir vorher schon in der region waren mehrmals auch gesehen haben,
was da passiert ne wenn so keine ahnung mal direkt.
Weiß ich nicht zehn oder fünfzehn verletzte auf einmal kommen deswegen situation davon angeschaut haben wir arbeiten auch die lokalen partnern partnerinnen und dann überlegt haben wie was was was können wir da jetzt machen da natürlich geguckt wie machen das andere und haben dann gesagt zu nee.
Das brauchen wir jetzt nicht ne weil das das wird die situation in so ein kriegsgebiet nicht gerecht also standard geschichten wir bauen den container so und so aus und da ist unser,
und da kann man natürlich viele rotstift angesetzt und haben gesagt es frisst platz das ist geld das braucht jetzt nicht,
und dann ist es viel tatsächlich dass wir während des baus dann gemerkt haben so blöd.
Das passt dann irgendwann doch nicht mehr wenn man jetzt so und so viel mitnehmen dann müssen wir doch noch ein zweites und dann kann man noch einen anhänger dazu das ist ein bisschen tatsächlich während des baus entstanden weil ja viele sachen parallel liefen der technische bau,
auch mit äh das krankenhaus sollte autark sein das heißt zum teil solar stromversorgung und ansonsten generatoren,
und es sollte aber auch nur so wasser aufbereitung das kam immer so stück für stück dazu dass man gedacht hat mensch da haben wir noch gar nicht dran gedacht das müssen wir auch noch lösen,
und dann hat man das projekt heute wieder angepasst.
Da braucht man dann schon so gewisse hacker skills auch.
Oder also ich meine ist ja auch so ein bisschen dieser coach mit wir haben nicht viel aber lass mal trotzdem was draus bauen wo kommt also meine hundertfünfzigtausend für komplettes krankenhaus ist jetzt irgendwie dann doch ich meine das kann man für ein wohnmobil ausgeben.
Auf jeden fall da war natürlich auch noch sachspenden dabei nimmt man auch sagen ne man kann auch hundertfünfzigtausend alleine für ein mädchen das gerät aufgeben durchaus ähm genau.
Was habt ihr da so für technik drin also musst du dir dann euch technik auch noch selber bauen als mein medizinischen geräte baut man sicher jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres selber oder.
Tatsächlich machen wir das auch gerade ähm das aber nach,
entstanden das war nämlich genau der punkt dass wir immer gemerkt haben
das beispiel so dies so die kreislauf überwachung ne das so einen patienten da liegen und willst du wissen wie schnell schlägt das herz hoch ist der blutdruck das willst du die ganze zeit wissen weil es vielleicht schwer verletzt,
da kannst du so ein gerät kaufen das wenn er glück hast und billig für neu blick das vielleicht bei eins fünf.
Geht so der mittlere bereichen zu dreitausend euro und das geht dann aber nach nach oben ist es offen.
Dann haben wir auch schon gesagt verdammt wenn wir jetzt wirklich sagen würden wir wollen das abstellen und wollen sagen wir wollen irgendwie nachher zehn überwachungs plätze haben.
Da haben wir die ersten dreißigtausend euro nur für die geräte ausgegeben.
Und das ist vielleicht manchmal ganz geil leute zusammenkommen die von vielen sachen überhaupt keine ahnung haben ich zum beispiel ich kann so eine kreislauf bewachung anschließen und ich weiß dass es ein ekg seit hundert jahren gibt,
das ist eine technik die ist das uralt ne dass man weiß im herzen da fließt ein strom der will man messen und dann ist das genau das ding dass ich zum beispiel auf dem acker community zu gegangen bin und gesagt hab mal leute wenn es seit jahren gibt.
Tag das kann ja eigentlich nicht mehr wie sagt man das so ne markt sein es muss eigentlich klar sein wie man das macht wieso kann man das nicht selber für billig bauen also man kann das sonst alles mögliche messen,
und dann kam bewegung ins spiel und leute meinte so ja wir warum dann kannst du doch kaufen und als,
problemlage den den hackern die das können bewusst war,
da kam das ding auf zugesagt haben gut wir machen jetzt mal was ingenieure wir wollen so ein gerät bauen das soll ein bausatz sein das können die idealerweise vor ort selber löten und das darf keine kosten das soll so was wie hundert euro kosten.
Das ist so zwischen einzelne projekte die sowie letzten zwei jahre liefen wo wir gerade auf der auf der zielgeraden sind.
Da kommen ja viele sachen zusammen irgendwann muss ich ein bisschen auch um die um die it dahinter kümmern also die die die die software vielleicht schreiben so gar nicht alleine oder ich hatte null ahnung von aber es ist total schön.
Wenn mich leute zusammen für uns ganz unterschiedlichen bereichen wenn ich sagen kann ja das bräuchte es im feld ich hab sozusagen den case.
Und jemand anderes sagt so naja ich hab die skills ich muss ins case besser verstehen und dann können wir zusammen dann entwickeln wir schon was.
Das heißt ihr habt euch im prinzip selber gebaut aber revers ingenieur heißt ja ihr habt erstmal ein anderes genommen und geguckt wie funktioniert das eigentlich intern tatsächlich was es da so drin und wie kann man das dann quasi mit anderen methoden nachbauen.
Genau tatsächlich ist das so ein ansatz ich weiß nicht ob das so gebräuche ich ist in so im spaces dass wir sagen wir müssen das nicht komplett die zwei haben sondern wir suchen schon zum beispiel auch den kontakt zu unis.
In dem fall war das hier die beuth in berlin und der h w.
Weil meistens sind ja die die profis in dem bereich die suchen die hände ringen.
Bauen immer irgendwas im semester um studis was beizubringen und dann schmeißen wir weg.
Und da war zum beispiel eine professorin die bäcker die meinte also der cases ist so spannend weil wir bringen den leuten dabei wie man so ein ekg wie die technik gebaut sein muss,
dann gehen die bei uns im studio abschluss weggehen zu den firmen und bei den firmen lernen sie wie man es halt quasi so verpasst hält,
das ist quasi der hacker zuhause an seinem schreibtisch nicht mehr reparieren kann oder,
so halt und das war ein punkt das sieht ja selber und meinte nö also super geil wenn ihr als organisation und quasi diesen case gibt dann das nochmal zusammen daran arbeiten und so finden dann auch studis zu uns den weg die da hätte ich das gerade gelernt haben wie man das macht und so kann man so.
Ich will ja auch ein interessanter aspekt an dieser stelle so dieser aspekt der repariert
ja das ist ja schau mal bei so kommerziellen produkten eher sagen wir mal so immer so so leid klagen so ich kann mein iphone nicht mehr selber reparieren und so weiter aber ist natürlich dann auch irgendwie so eine komplexe materie und die allerwenigsten machen es halt wirklich aber hier
in eurem ansatz ist das ja ja entscheidet das ja unter umständen über leben und tod ob man in der lage ist,
das zeug halt auch am laufen zu halten und was ist wenn es mal kaputt ist dann kannst du ja nicht beim hersteller in deutschland anrufen und sagen irgendwie software-update oder so
von daher ganz gut wenn das wenn man das sozusagen auch alles selber verstanden dokumentiert hat und irgendwie auch klare reparatur anleitung.
Was was gibt's da noch so andere sachen die so diesen lecker brutto und du hast gesagt ihr hättet hacker communities angesprochen welche wo wie.
Na wir machen relativ viel zeige ich euch jetzt auch keine ahnung habe,
wir sind ganz gut connected devices würde ich sagen äh nur mit leuten aus liebe ist auch auch aktiv sind der der uns heute macht ja bei uns sein sein liberale flip projekt auf unserer c fräse.
Liebe flip gehabt das ist schon so ein bußgeld genau.
Ach so.
Ähm.
C insgesamt zum teil auch über die festival kultur wenn man sich dann persönlich kennengelernt hat,
die leute dann da vielleicht die auf dem festival stellen
sind wir damit ganz gut wir sind jetzt seit zwei drei jahren auf dem auf dem auf dem kongress auch mit dem eigenen bereich vertreten war dieses jahr ja auch mit bei diesem monkeys
auf dem auf dem camp vertreten haben damit so sachen gebaut und,
genau welches basis die leute zum beispiel aktiv sind weiß ich gar nicht so genau da gibt's ja die kommerziellen spaces wo er die dort wieder arbeiten und auch mal unterstützen ich weiß wohin für uns mal sachen im.
Oder so hat.
Wenn ich das leben.
Wenn sie das tablet.
Happy das muss irgendwie klappt das ein kommerzielles ding hier in berlin wenn ich mich nicht irre darf ab da mal ein freund von uns da sachen auf deren cd gemacht als sie noch keiner hat.
Finde ich gibt es konnte ich nicht gibt es ja.
Es gibt immer mehr von diesen makers basis die tatsächlich den kommerziellen einsatz fahren das gibt es in berlin dieses motion laptop,
riesig ist ja natürlich immer ganz andere möglichkeiten weil die wirklich maschinen auch einfach,
einkaufen weil die eskalieren können wenn sie halt sagen wir bieten ja unsere dienste an das kostet bei uns ist natürlich so dass wir immer wieder stück für stück gesagt haben zum beispiel leute wir bräuchten ein schweißgerät.
Hat jemand geld zu spenden schweißgerät wollen das und das damit machen und so ist das über die jahre langsam,
gewachsen also wir sind eher würde ich sagen also die werkstatt und natürlich nicht vergleichbar mit so lebt davon angesprochen wir haben da niemand drucker.
Obwohl das stimmt gar nicht wir haben schon eine ausstellung,
was kann ich das herr kam irgendwann in so eine.
Ja gut aber ihr habt natürlich schon ganz anderen aspekt von mit dieser mit dieser nachhaltigen produktion von von von sachen und dann natürlich auch noch mit dieser stoßrichtung medizinische versorgung das ist ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so so so und darauf sind ja auch andere laboratorien nicht unbedingt,
drauf ausgelegt.
Also diese.
Dieser aspekt dass diese mediziner geräte ebenso natürlich so hohen anforderungen unterliegen dem finde ich ja hier deshalb
nochmal sehr interessant weil
in einer in den situationen in denen wir uns jetzt hier befinden erwarten wir natürlich schon dass eben besonders hohe standards an an die mediziner geräte,
angelegt werden beschwerden uns wenn die die herzschrittmacher zu hacken sind oder so ne das sind so unsere problemchen ja,
während in anderen teilen der erde eben so etwas wie die die das der einbau eines herzschrittmacher ist oder so eben weiter ferne ist.
Wenn ihr jetzt mit so etwas in den einsatz geht,
dann seid ihr auch in in aufträgen unterwegs,
spielt das da eine rolle das euch gesagt wird also üblicherweise wenn solche solche standards und anforderungen haben wir einmal,
ursprünglich mal den sinn diese technik auf einen auf ein mindestmaß an,
qualität zu bringen und dann entwickeln sich im weiteren verlauf einfach,
zu markt eintritts barrieren
für konkurrenten ja sodass also gesagt wird hier das muss aber alles nach den hundertachtzigtausend standards und zertifizierung sein die im zweifel dann die hersteller nochmal selber geschrieben haben einfach nur damit bloß keine auf die idee kommt zu konkurrieren,
und wer das jetzt in dem in dem umfeld auch so dass sie sagen hier ihr müsst aber
eure geräte müssen so und so zertifiziert sein oder ist da dann auch klar dass gesagt wird ne wir wissen alle dass euers genauso gut funktioniert und euer monitoring system muss ja jetzt auch vielleicht nicht,
falls die epg diagnose machen sondern halt erkennen ob jemand open herzflimmern und ob schlägt was ja sehr viel geringere anforderungen sind.
Ich würde das direkt nochmal ganz kurz zu sagen also wir fahren ja den also wir sind ja nicht so so,
klar fisch an dieses gebunden gar nicht also ich freue mich mega wenn ich das geld aus irgendwelchen fun links habe mir ein ein defibrillator beatmet gerät vom markt zu kaufen.
Weil es ist natürlich auch eine belastung na wenn du jetzt sagen würdest wir machen immer alles selber und sagen das funktioniert genauso gut dann hast du ja auch eine unfassbare.
Deswegen sind das so zwei sachen die parallel laufen wenn wir in den einsatz gehen wir arbeiten natürlich dann mit vielen sachen,
die wir von der stange kaufen auch weil diese einsätze sehr oft,
und es waren ja vorhin schon sehr entwicklungsprozess für dieses vital parameter monitoring das wir selber gebaut und das läuft seit zwei jahren.
Wir können unsere einsätze gar nicht darauf abstimmen dass wir sagen alles was wir brauchen bauen wir selber das ist so ein parallel prozess ist schon.
Anteil in 'ner ganz klassischen hilfsorganisation haben nur dass wir da bereiche abdecken die andere nicht so abdecken und dann geht's genau darum wir kaufen ja auch unsere notfall rucksäcke natürlich und nehmen die nicht selbst oder sowas.
Und wenn wir dann nur sehen wir gehen jetzt zum beispiel nach syrien arbeiten dann im krankenhaus und da gibts außer unserem gekauften monitor überhaupt keinen dann stoßen wir parallel diesen prozess an und sagen gut,
das muss man nochmal anschauen ob man das nicht lösen kann und dann ist es nachher auch eine frage von community das zu diskutieren ob ihn die ansprüche reichen oder nicht da würden wir auch nicht kommen und würden in syrien der kuscheln selbstverwaltung sagen.
Guck mal hier wir bringen detail das ist die lösung sondern würden halt das einfach transparent sagen hier das ist eine open source entwicklung,
das kann das und das es hat nicht die und die tests die man vielleicht bei einem gerät woanders hat da keine community auch immer noch für sich entscheiden wir wollen das so aber nicht.
Geht's wirklich mehr darum zu sagen wir wollen diese probleme anfassen wollen lösungen entwickeln und die dann wieder auf augenhöhe kommunizieren ob sie denn quasi ihren weg ins feld.
Also hier in deutschland wird das so dieses selbstgebaute ekg würde nie eine zulassung bekommen,
spannenderweise in den kommissionen die entscheiden was für eine zulassung nur von nöten ist sitzen auch die großen firmen mit drin die schon am markt existent produkte bauen,
also die können ihren eigenen markt quasi für knappen,
und das wäre auch gar nicht unser ziel weil wir auch kein gewinn interesse dahinter haben und dann vor ort wäre es tatsächlich so,
wir sagen würden hier ist ein angebot das müsst ihr überlegen.
Man könnte auch sagen gemeinsam zum beispiel noch belegen deine innere testphase eintritt oder nicht und dann kommst du dir auf gesellschaften zu wenn man von syrien weggehen wir waren letztes jahr auch in nepal,
bei bei bei freunden an der vorträge halten über dieses thema die meinten auch die hotels sessions in den ganz entfernten thailand die haben überhaupt.
Und dann ist natürlich schnell dass eine lokale community was ich sagen kann wir haben kein geld wir haben keinen zug,
dann nehmen wir das natürlich bevor wir gar nichts haben das ist aber auch so eine medizin ethische diskussion die wir ja nicht quasi für die führen können sondern die man dann mal miteinander führen muss.
Stellt sich natürlich trotzdem die frage man will natürlich trotzdem verlässliche geräte haben also nur weil sie jetzt keine zulassung in deutschland haben wir es noch lange nicht dass er auch funktionieren.
Absolut.
Die frage wie man da überhaupt einen prozess aufbauen kann da auch 'ne gewisse zuverlässigkeit jenseits etablierter zulassung strukturen zu realisieren.
Ist immer die frage.
Das ist immer die frage ist natürlich wir sind ja jetzt ja sehr in diesem medizinischen kontext also in dem make-up space an sich also mit kapital parameter monitoring ein schwieriges wort,
das ist ja wirklich jetzt und sehr medizinisches.
Ausschließlich medizinisches gerät,
bauen ja auch ganz andere sachen so wasser
l k w für bosnien haben wir gebaut da geht's dann gar nicht darum irgendwas krass zu entwickeln sondern geht's wirklich darum zu sagen die winter keine möglichkeit zu duschen.
Eigene ist auch schon mal so die halbe miete ne.
Dann kaufen wir siebeneinhalbtonner in alten gebrauchten und bauen eine dusche mit thermen geschichten rein wir haben ein erdogan system entwickelt wie man aus so flugzeugen aus dem mal fallschirmspringen kann,
kleinere hilf lieferung abwerfen kann das einfach mal so eine idee wird haben was.
Muss doch was geben weil auf dem markt gibt es wiederum nur so riesen lösungen,
das militär flieger ab schmeißen kannst also geht's auch schon so logistischen geschichten müllverbrennung hatte ich vorhin schon gesagt also da geht's in ganz verschiedene bereiche die aber alle mit humanitären oder hat ökologischen probleme zu tun haben.
Kriegt ja alles was ihr so so so braucht dann auch irgendwie schnell hin oder hättet ihr da quasi noch bedarf für finde junge.
Immer bedarf also immer bedarf dass dieser make-up base noch noch voller wird mehr leute sich engagieren also wer mag mega gerne wir versuchen natürlich auch
remote leuten die möglichkeit zu geben sich zu beteiligen ist natürlich schwierig wenn die entwicklungsprozess geht das schon mal wenn jemand jetzt aus aus münchen sagt wer hat lust auf so ein prozess beteiligt zu sein
es ist natürlich immer schwierig bei der werkstatt die jetzt einfach sehr.
Ja aber was weiß ich es gibt ja auch mal so platinen bedarf oder so man lehrer zu machen für eine steuern oder sowas.
Wir werden da auf jeden fall dass es gibt viel mehr ideen als menschen da sind die die alle umsetzen könnten.
Es ist gut weil manchmal gibt's auch leute die können immer 'ne menge umsetzen aber den mangels aus irgendwelchen gründen immer so aus äh entweder an ideen oder an anreizen diese dann auch mal umzusetzen und da macht das eine ganz gute paarung sein.
Dieses system das klingt ja auch also klickt auf den ersten,
blick vielleicht gar nicht so kompliziert ist eine kiste kommt kommt an fallschirm.
Kannst du mal erklären wie problematisch das im zweifelsfall ist so etwas zu bauen und ist euers im einsatz.
Ähm nein also tatsächlich ist es zertifiziert worden in der schweiz durch das bundesamt für zivilluftfahrt die haben das angeguckt
das komplizierte bei solchen geschichte sich bei luftfahrt wenn du jetzt in staaten wie deutschland anfängst im amt zu erzählen möchte ich gerne sachen aus dem flieger schmeißen.
Das finde ich erstmal gar nicht so lustig das da gibt's noch eine menge gründe was man alles nicht so darf und dann,
mir gleichzeitig das ding nicht gesagt haben das muss wieder günstig sein und idee kam daher dass wir gesagt haben ja diese diese notfalls schirme aus dem paragliding die müssen alle paar jahre ausgetauscht werden,
aus versicherungstechnisch gründen selbst wenn die niemals geöffnet worden irgendwann sind die quasi abgelaufen wird das ist doch quatsch,
das material wird ja nicht zwangsläufig schlecht warum versuchen wir nicht mal aus diesem fallschirm was zu machen und dann kam wieder ein entwicklungsprozess sachen auf und man gemerkt hat okay mit was für 'ne geschwindigkeit klatscht man eigentlich mit so 'nem fallschirm auf.
Wo man dann nur der körper feder das quasi dynamisch ab,
da ist eine starke kiste dran hängst dann geht diese ganze belastung komplett in die kiste und in das was du eventuell drin ist.
Und da haben wir dann angefangen also das falsche system haben unsere schweizer partner von der hpi sich dann gesetzt das zu machen und wir haben versucht dieses problem des aufpreis zu lösen,
und haben damit zu verschiedenen,
formation geguckt eindämmung system zu zu haben was quasi die die energie aufnimmt und über performance energie quasi den den den haupt impact rausnimmt und.
Ist die indische tief das lese ich jetzt mal als leute piloten die sich irgendwie einsetzen für solche flüge.
Kleine aber super nice crew aus der schweiz da sind jetzt keine keine verkehrspolitik roten also nicht alle zumindest das sind die die mit sea-watch zusammen im mittelmeer die moonbird betreiben und nachher für die,
boden suchen und das ja auch wieder das nette ne also da bin ich dann zwei dreimal im einsatz mit geflogen als,
als als man das observatorium ne also da mit den augen am am fernglas und so entstehen dann so projekte dass man auf den rückflug einfach in schlafen konnte sagt was können wir noch mit zeugen eigentlich machen werden wir noch ganz andere humanitäre probleme,
und so ist es tatsächlich entstanden zu sagen ja,
gerade wenn man eine kleinere projekte versorgen will die jetzt nicht so eine so eine cd hundertdreißig an so ein riesen flugzeug brauchen debatte idee und dann haben wir uns dran gemacht und.
Ist zertifiziert das würde ich dazu sagen ja wäre einsatzfähig wir sind gerade mit den syrien projekten einfach so gebunden dass dass wir gerade nicht,
die kapazitäten haben zu überlegen wo man das noch umsetzen könnte das liegt jetzt sozusagen im regal und wartet drauf dass wir dafür ein projekt stricken.
Ja wenn deutschland so weitermacht kriegen wir auch bald wieder eine luftbrücke dann können wir das brauchen.
Genau.
Aber wie habt ihr das getestet also.
Da sieht man da auf dem video bei uns auf der homepage also am anfang also es könnte sein dass menschen ich weiß das natürlich nicht das am anfang einfach mal nachts von irgendwelchen brücken geschmissen haben glaube ich nicht weil ich ja ne also.
Geht nicht und wenn das denn so gewesen wäre und man irgendwann gewusst hätte okay grundsätzlich scheint das so funktionieren,
hat man dann in der schweiz einfach mal nachgefragt beim beim bundesamt für zivilluftfahrt eigentlich mit der erwartung wir werden auf jeden fall nein sagen und da waren die ganz interessiert und würde es mal gucken und dann haben wir das auf einem.
Ehemaligen militärflughafen in der schweiz einfach aus dem flugzeug wir haben acht neun zehn tester würfel gemacht.
Genau und es hat sich das bundesamt für sie sofort angeguckt und das war total erfolgreich geschaut ne entsteht daraus eine gefahr für für das flugzeug für die fliegerei kann da irgendwas passieren die meint ne das ist so wie das entwickelt habt das sichern und,
kann man jetzt machen.
Ein ehemaliger militärflughafen so so.
Da war platz davor keiner um.
Ja das bietet sich anders nicht über der stadt zu üben.
Jetzt haben wir viel gehört darüber was so euer ansatz ist sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal kurz auf die aktuelle situation,
eingehen also ihr habt wie viele mission gerade überhaupt am start nur die eine um die es jetzt geht oder gibt's.
Genau das läuft hier durchgehend und wir sind momentan
jetzt in syrien weil wir da auch ein ein relativ großes projekt gestartet hat wir hatten schon immer so eine immer wir hatten seit anderthalb jahren eine prima also so,
grund gesundheitsversorgung station in rakka der ehemaligen hauptstadt vom,
und haben jetzt seit april in einem großen camp vor ort ein krankenhaus,
diesmal kein mobiles sondern tatsächlich ein krankenhaus auch wieder mit,
op mit isoliert station für für infektionen erkrankungen und das ist für uns das kleine organisationen,
in so einem kriegsgebiet natürlich ein riesen projekt und da könnten wir gerade mehr einfach gar nicht.
Wo genau befindet sich das.
Das ist lecker siehst du da zu deiner zu deiner rechten.
Also ihr seht das ja so natürlich alles nicht ich habe hier gerade mal eine karte auf den bildschirm geworfen also wir reden jetzt von nordsyrien und das ist ja auch,
traditionelle kunde region das hat die türkei schon immer sehr gestört kurdistan ist ja ein komplexes gebilde und das ursprüngliche siedlung gebiet der
kurden digital teilweise in syrien teilweise in der türkei teilweise auch im iran und es gibt halt rund um abiy gibt's halt einen,
schon seit längerem extrem stabilen ungefährdet,
bereich aber diese ganzen rand gebiete sind natürlich dann
immer unter feuer gewesen und kurdistan ist halt so wieder das friedliche folgte man bisher einfach noch kein raum hat geben wollen das ist so ein bisschen
dauert drama ich hab auch schon mal einen podcast dazu gemacht aber auch nochmal drauf verlinken wen das interessiert die ganze situation insbesondere natürlich in syrien ist jetzt durch den,
kriegt der letzten jahre besonders verworren
der stand bis vor wenigen tagen war schlecht der im norden gab es relativ befristete zonen teilweise hergestellt eben durch.
Die erfolge natürlich der der kurden im kampf gegen das assad regime und natürlich dann auch,
gegen den i s der versucht hat das wiederum in dieses macht vakuum reinzubringen
es gab immer wieder auseinandersetzungen es gibt ja in syrien denn auch noch so eine türkische sprachige minderheit die natürlich dann zwangsläufig mit der,
türkei wieder ganz gut verbunden ist aber generell ist natürlich die präsenz der kurden der türkei immer ein dorn im auge gewesen aber so richtig machen was sie wollten konnten sie dort halt auch nicht weil natürlich die amerikaner auch noch da waren und vor allem bis vor kurzem die luft hoheit dort,
gesichert haben auf die jetzt der idiot trump aus vollkommen unklaren gründen verzichtet hat,
erdogan hat die gelegenheit sofort,
ergriffen und den krieg eröffnet und das ist jetzt sozusagen die situation dass jetzt euer team in wo genau sitzt jetzt in.
Wir sitzen also
die internationalen sind gerade gestern abgezogen zum einen weil ich schichtwechsel für die medizinerin gewesen wäre zum anderen genau wegen der entwicklung da kann ich ja mal ganz kurz versuchen das zusammenzufassen,
unser projekt ist bei hasse ist eine der ganz großen städte da in der region und in der nähe von hasse so eine stunde fahrt entfernt ist alkohol mitten in der wüste und da gibt's ein camp mit,
sauber für zehntausend menschen geplant und es war dann ganz schnell siebzigtausend und es war klar dass von diesem,
sehr sehr viele frauen und kinder,
aus quasi eigentlich dem dem dem dem den sozialen staat hinter dem eis stammen.
Das war so in der in diesem camp so passen nicht zwanzig dreißigtausend menschen sind die zwanzig aktiv gekämpft haben aber die familien hinterher fahren und immer noch auch zu dieser ideologie steht.
Zusätzlich in den campen paar tausend menschen untergebracht also bisschen bisschen sicherer untergebracht quasi die aus allen möglichen verschiedenen ländern kam und durchaus für ein eis entweder gekämpft haben oder,
so was wie das logistischen rückgrat waren,
also jeder hat natürlich nachdem da ist fast besiegt war versucht zu sagen ich hab nicht leute erschossen ich war koch ich werde technikbereich weil sonst was,
genau diese leute sind in diesem camp in alkohol die medizinische lage war ganz furchtbar und im frühjahr meinte die weltgesundheitsorganisation wir rufen jetzt die notstand aus weil wie das hier ist.
Das geht gar nicht und dann war es immer wieder sehr schwer eine organisation zu finden die sagt ja übernehmen dieses projekt weil da stehen quasi zwei drei sachen dagegen.
Es ist schwierig in syrien zu arbeiten es ist ein bürgerkriegsland ist total zerrissen es gibt sehr viele eis schläfer zellen es gibt immer noch etwas prämien die da sind und die meisten klassischen hilfsorganisationen sagen da gehen wir nicht hin.
Wir sind zu gefährlich.
Sonst so gefährlich wir warten das nächste erdbeben in nepal das wird auch durchaus einfach nur das ist der nächste punkt so ein erdbeben in nepal wird in der presse danach guck mal die arme die brauchen jetzt hilfe.
Spendet hier und dann kann man da auch richtig spenden abgreifen wenn wir jetzt sagen würde in der wüste und wir versorgen die familien die immer noch sagen wir sind der islamische staat.
Da muss man da schon tatsächlich mal drüber diskutieren tatsächlich auch mit vielen leuten aus der linken,
und den erklären dass ja grundlegende menschenrechte allen leuten zustehen und das irgendwie ja teil unserer aufgeklärten gesellschaft ist und unsere.
Humanitär heißt.
Das ist was ursächlich humanitär ist dass sie die kids schon mal gar nichts dafür können wenn er so ein siebenjähriger sagt ich bin vom islamischen staat.
Der ist aber nur in der gesellschaft aufgewachsen dann kann ich ihnen viel mehr dafür auch nicht verurteilen das zweite ist halt tatsächlich.
Also wenn wir davon abrücken und das hätte ich nicht man hört dann schon so sprüche wir warum hast du dich in der wüste verrecken.
Dann denk ich so ein bisschen ja weil wir dann auch nicht besser sind als genau die mit ihrer ideologie.
Ja vor allem und genau solche situationen haben wir im prinzip diese gefolgschaft überhaupt am anfang überhaupt erst erzählt weil sich eben die anderen staaten um die leute nicht gekümmert.
Genau situation jetzt ganz aktuell ist halt so die kurden hatten mit dem assad-regime vorher gar nicht so richtig kämpfen wir hatten so ein stillhalten ding die haben sich gar nicht krass gekriegt,
sondern es gab da nur zwei große,
reiche noch in diesen kurdischen gebieten nämlich in comic und den hass selber wo das regime noch leute hatte zwei garnison oder was und dies war so ein bisschen so ein stillhalten ding,
da wurde jahrelang nicht wirklich darüber gesprochen weil sich auf hat ja mit anderen dingen oder anderen rebellen gebieten beschäftigt hat und dieser ganze syrische konflikt ist ja unfassbar.
Komplex und da ist ja aus einer aus einer emanzipation revolution bewegung schnell auch 'ne ja was ist da noch übrig also sehr sehr viele milizen haben nicht mehr viele initiative sondern sind tatsächlich islamistische.
Was jetzt passiert ist dadurch dass erdogan den hauptfeind kurden tatsächlich sieht er hat ja mit den islamistischen milizen überhaupt kein problem im gegenteil die kämpfe auf seiner seite jetzt
der hat mit den kurden problemen sagt immer schon das sind alles terroristen es gab nie angriffe in den letzten jahren von.
Diesen kurdischen gebieten auf die türkei aber erdogan hat das trotzdem hinbekommen zu sagen dass es eine bedrohung für meinen staat ich brauche deine sicherheitszone und bislang war das so.
Das ist eigentlich ein deal gab dass die amis gesagt haben ja aber du marschierst hier nicht ein sondern wir können gemeinsame patrouilliert machen,
und die anwesenheit der amerikaner war in dem moment ein schutz eigentlich für diese region und videos meinte schon grad meinte es ne der,
orange voll trottel hat dann äh irgendwie einfach ganz kurz vor sie mal entschieden ich ziehe die leute ab und ich gebe erdogan quasi grünes licht.
Und was wir jetzt haben ist eine situation die in einer woche absolut eskaliert ist.
Die türkei hat angefangen mit luftschläge hat also diese diese flugverbotszone die es vorher gab hat die usa auch nicht mehr umgesetzt das heißt türkische jets,
haben alle möglichen stellungen der kurden bombardiert aber nicht nur das ist in der krankenhäuser angegriffen worden versorgung station angegriffen worden,
zivile konvoi journalisten sind schon ums leben gekommen.
Und das perfide bei der geschichte ist ja dass die türkei gerade gar nicht initial mit ihrer eigenen armee einzieht sondern erstmal diese türkisch unterstützten milizen da rein schickt diese islamistischen milizen,
die für unfassbar viele gräueltaten und kriegsverbrechen bekannt sind die sie vorher schon in afrin begangen haben letztes jahr und jetzt gibt's da auch schon wieder berichte von erschießung von zivilisten und,
erschossen ne kämpfer und zivilisten den wir in die köpfe abgeschnitten und ist ja heute fertig dann.
Leider unglücklicherweise so dass leute so bescheuert sind das zu filmen und auch dieses jahr netzwerke hoch zu laden das heißt selbst wenn kein journalist mehr vor ort sind kann man gerade monitoren.
Wie dramatisch diese lage vor ort ist,
und dadurch dass die usa die kurden so hat fallen lassen haben die kurden sich in auseinandersetzung und verhandlungen mit dem regime begeben und haben gesagt.
Wir stehen hier alleine wir werden aus der luft kaputt gebombt es wenn diese milizen ja ein marschieren die türkei kommt hinterher dann wird es der kurdischen.
Bevölkerung einfach antragen gehen da wird geplündert gemordet,
vergewaltigt wir brauchen schutz und haben quasi ihre ihre autonomie.
Anscheinend äh als verhandlungs- angebot auf den tisch gelegt,
und haben äh vorgestern tatsächlich dann das ging rasend schnell wie innerhalb von von,
uhr gab's die ersten verlautbarungen,
da ist ein deal vereinbart worden bis hin zu nachts waren schon überall in der region auch wieder syrische regime truppen unterwegs.
Und jetzt haben wir die abgefahrene situation.
Dass die türkei sagt es interessiert mich gar nicht ob die kurden mit dem regime in verhandlungen gehen und sich dem regime unterordnen wir marschieren trotzdem weiter ein wir halten uns auch nicht an diese dreißig kilometer zone eigentlich mal gesagt wir gehen nur dreißig kilometer rein.
Auf dem kompletten landstrich sondern sie sind auf dem weg richtung rakka sie sind das haben die eigentlich auch schon tiefer drinsteckt.
Teilweise eingenommen sodass man gerade davon ausgehen kann dass die einfach sagen würdet was wir vorhaben verlauten lassen sicherheitszone wir gucken mal wie weit wir kommen.
Die wollen eigentlich im prinzip kurdistan im norden syriens türkisch besetzt.
Sie wollen sowieso dass es keine kurdischen milizen gibt und keine komische selbstverwaltung,
und erdogans plan ist ja einfach alle syrischen geflüchteten die drei bis vier millionen die gerade in der türkei sind dann quasi zu zwingen zurück genau diese region zu gehen wo dann diese islamistischen milizen quasi die,
kontrolle haben sollen und sagte so ist das problem die sollen zurück nach syrien.
Scheiße im wahrsten sinne des wortes drauf wo diese geflüchteten herkommen also viele geflüchtete ganz aus dem süden syriens will er dann jetzt in den tiefen nordosten verpflanzt sagen ist das wie das problem von syrien.
Politisch steckt da einfach unfassbar viel drin weil man sagt ja ich kämpfe das halt frei da sie liegt da drei bis vier millionen menschen an die region ist gar nicht ausgestattet dafür,
und sagt ich bau der städte und dörfer das zahlt die eu die eu hat jetzt aber auch schon.
Die haben wir dann die flüchtlinge nicht mehr und das ist ja die größte angst dass dann wieder irgendwie so eine flüchtlingswelle kommt und deswegen haben sich die ganze zeit auf diesen deal mit der türkei überhaupt eingelassen was ich natürlich jetzt nicht gerade auszahlt.
Ich will mich gar nicht noch viel tiefer in das politische verlieren das ding ist tatsächlich.
In kriegsgebieten arbeiten ist ja in den letzten zwei drei jahren so ein bisschen zu unserer spezialität geworden,
wir haben dieses krankenhaus in dem camp wir haben dann gesagt als die kampfhandlung ausgebrochen sind wir
unterstützen auch wieder andere krankenhäuser und so medizinerin tamara geholfen die verletzten zu versorgen und unsere idee war natürlich also wir bleiben weil
das ist etwas was wir können und wir versuchen halt tatsächlich,
die die die wackelige gesundheit struktur solange aufrecht zu halten,
wie möglich jetzt ist es wie gesagt so unsere lokalen kolleginnen unsere angestellten fort sind noch da unsere krankenhaus läuft unsere station in rakka läuft aber die situation ist so an.
Dass man eigentlich gar nicht weiß,
was was was jetzt demnächst passieren wird wer hat eigentlich die oberhof ist das regime haben die kurden noch die grenze übergänge in der hand also alles was in den letzten jahren aufgebaut wurde was immer stabiler lief.
Unterstützung aus dem irak und aus damaskus internationale hilfsorganisation die langsam angefangen projekte zu entwickeln hat die türkei innerhalb von wenigen tagen in grund und boden gehauen.
Und diese situation die wir gerade vor ort haben wir reden jetzt schon von über vierhunderttausend vertriebenen in der region der winter kommt.
Die wenigen städte dies weiter südlich der kampf zone gibt die sind voll darunter ist wüste da weiß man gar nicht wo man die unterbringen will also es droht eine humanitäre katastrophe tatsächlich ungeahnten ausmaßes,
das muss man ganz klar zu sagen und das war immer klar das war auch schon im januar klar da hatten wir den treffen im irak mit,
all den operationen die operations da machen da waren die analysen von und wir waren schon in die türkei hier einmarschiert.
Dann geht 's hier nochmal richtig ab dann reden wir im am ende des tages von von fünfhundert sechshundert siebenhunderttausend vertriebenen.
Und da gehen wir davon aus dass die türkische truppen sind wenn du jetzt von den islamistischen milizen ausgehst die,
tatsächlich auch sich an null genfer konvention halten dann.
Und das ist gerade so der punkt vor denen wir stehen diese woche so ein bisschen zwischen krassem aktionismus und auch totaler verzweiflung dass wir einfach sehen wie halt diese stabilität die geschaffen wurde wie die wirklich in kürzester zeit einfach,
ja
komplett verkloppt wurde und wir jetzt gerade gucken müssen wo können wir vor ort am sinnvollsten helfen es gibt natürlich also es gibt überall was zu tun und lokalen angestellten die.
Rütteln was das zeug hält sind natürlich gleichzeitig in gefahr durch diese aktiven kampfhandlung.
Ja das ist so die situation in der wir gerade stehen.
Und was heißt das jetzt konkret für euer team vor ort was sind jetzt die schritte also ihr habt glaube ich gestern da maßnahmen eingeleitet.
Wir haben gestern nochmal die menschen die kein syrischen pass haben ähm aus der region rausgeholt.
Vor dem hintergrund ist einfach unklar war wie das jetzt mit den grenzen mit mit den grenzen besetzungen wie reagiert das regime es war einfach durch den über den deal der da geschlossen wurde ist noch nicht allzu viel bekannt.
Also rausgeholt heißt die sind nicht mehr.
Wir sind jetzt im nordirak da ist sozusagen auch unsere base von der aus wie operieren.
Und euer mobiles hospital ist aber jetzt nicht gleich darüber gefahren.
Das mobile hospital haben wir schon vor einem jahr unsere lokalen partner organisationen quasi übergeben haben gesagt so benutzt das wo ihr es am nötigsten seht,
ist jetzt eures das ist auch unser ansatz ist findet dann sagen wollen da gibt's dann auch um um,
wissens und technologie transfer und wir hatten ja wie gesagt diese in rakka die station und dieses,
dreißig betten krankenhaus in alkohol da wird jetzt zum gegner das unsere lokalen angestellten dass wir gerade halt gucken wie wir das.
Viele ideen was man gerade irgendwie machen müsste wir müssen sehen ob wir verletzte von den front linien auch in diesem krankenhaus operieren können wie man das hier recherchiert wie sicher ist dieses camp noch weil in vielen
gefängnissen und in vielen camp familien ähm untergebracht sind,
jetzt auch ja die stimmung immer gefährlicher wird weil die sehen natürlich.
Die sehen eigentlich dass diese islamistischen milizen queen mary ihre verbündeten sind.
Die gemengelage vor ort dieses unbeschreiblich könnten wir drei stunden über sprechen wird immer noch keine analyse die den nächsten sechs stunden standhalten würde.
Ja nehme ich wollte jetzt konkret so was das jetzt für euch bedeutet.
Bedeutet es dieses krankenhaus muss weiterlaufen da tun wir alles für,
es ist relativ ist etwas weiter vor den kampfhandlung weg und es ist eine,
extrem wichtige ressource gerade wir müssen unseren lokalen partner hey was war akkord den kurdischen roten halb mond,
unterstützen wo es geht mit material mit finanzen mit lokalen personal dass wir ausheben können damit,
gerade auch die zivilbevölkerung noch versorgung bekommt wie gesagt in,
eine der angegriffen städte wurden auch gezielt für türkischen luftwaffe die krankenhäuser angegriffen das heißt,
das ganze gesundheitssystem rumort gerade weil wenn die türken und die mediziner rücken auch deswegen die krankenhäuser mit evakuiert werden mittlerweile,
und das ist für uns grad zwei hauptpunkte die medizinische versorgung und gleichzeitig was passiert bitte,
also mit dem internet displays people dass wir da auch gucken gerade geht's bei uns im wasserversorgung ganz initial und mittelfristig wollen wir auch schauen.
Wie ist es mit dem mit mit mit schalter also wo kommen die eigentlich unter,
wenn das wirklich vierhunderttausend menschen auf der flucht sind dann werden da neue entstehen müssen und,
wie gesagt also es kommen alle halbe stunde neue information rein und wir versuchen quasi mit den größten need.
Zu identifizieren wo wir kurzfristig helfen können und da direkt entweder mit den spenden die wir einnehmen oder personell durch unsere leute vor ort an dem was entgegenzusetzen.
Ja also ohne frage mit spenden es euch auf jeden fall geholfen das äh erklärt sich ja selbst.
Ich hab das gerade mal gemacht das kann ich empfehlen dieses spenden form von betterplace es ist sehr einfach und ist natürlich auch in den shownotes verlinkt.
Aber das ist nicht das einzige was euch hilft.
Ne wie gesagt also es ist doch so es wirkt dann jetzt wahrscheinlich auch gerade in unserer kommunikation ist social media so als wenn wir gerade nichts anderes machen es ist immer der zeit dass wir so eine kleine organisation sind,
manche andere
themen fallen in der kommunikation hinten runter der make-up space läuft ja weiter wir sind immer auf der suche nach interessierten menschen die die sich da beteiligen wollen wir sind immer auf der suche nach menschen die gut finden was wir machen und lust haben einfach so ne beim,
zu helfen weil das ist ein zu einem ganz großen großen in der außen kommunikation unfassbar schlecht,
das ist so ein bisschen nicht so aktionismus sind wir glaube ich ganz gut aber dieses,
dieses geschäft des spenden werben dieses irgendwo hingehen erzählen was wir machen wie wir das machen dass da sind wir absolute stimmt und stimmen drin drin.
Und auch da sind wir immer auf der suche also leute die sich dafür begeistern könnten zu sagen,
da lust das auf einer ganz praktischen ebene zu unterstützen und zu helfen das bekannter zu machen diskussion mit anzustoßen sind bei uns mehr als herzlich willkommen.
Ja aber ihr seid als verein als gemeinnütziger verein eingetragen und anerkannt dementsprechend können spenden auch vollständig abgesetzt werden als ausgaben ist ja immer nicht ganz unwichtig.
Jetzt kommt der tim wieder mit buchhaltung.
Ja das ist ein aspekt ich meine das heißt man kann auch das doppelte spenden es läuft das gleiche raus so.
So ist das nach oben sind die grenzen.
Was hast du noch eine frage.
Ähm ich habe noch tausend fragen aber ich will an dieser stelle echt mal nochmal wirklich mein tiefsten respekt hier
ausdrücken irgendwie man kann sich im leben viele inhalte und aufgaben suchen und irgendwie so eine verbindung aus einem
wirklich einfach in 'nem coolen anspruch und auch im so hohen hacken und gleichzeitig echt.
Wir haben jetzt noch gar nicht über die durchaus über die seelischen belastung gesprochen,
nichts so die umstände unter denen das team dort arbeitet sind glaube ich körperlich durchaus zehren psychisch auf jeden fall echt belastend das verdient wirklich
die höchste anerkennung was ihr da macht und sowas irgendwie,
so nach dem festival mal als wir haben ein problem erkannt da müssen wir uns mal drum kümmern aus dem boden zu stampfen finde ich so beeindruckend dass wir da wenig wenig worte zu einfallen das echt irre.
Also danke für die,
es ist natürlich vor zum beispiel sowas anzunehmen weil wir würden das nicht machen wenn wir nicht auf so einen eigenen antrieb hätten also ich glaube wir lieben schon diese arbeit ist auch tatsächlich ist eine unfassbar,
ganz unmittelbares ding mit einem mit dem mond hund feedback dass man bekommt und sind ja auch total viele schöne erlebnisse dabei ne also das ist ja das was gerade angesprochen hast mit dem emotionalen ding was unser team gerade glaube ich am meisten fertig macht ist
die lokalen kolleginnen die man irgendwie kennenlernt äh wo sie freundschaften beziehungen entwickeln jetzt in so einer situation zum beispiel allein lassen zu müssen,
aber immer hinter so einer interesse einer depressiven verstimmung steckt ja auch einfach der wert der sich vorher ergeben hat ne also
beim landtag über leute in ecken der welt kennen wo man sonst niemals hingekommen wäre und genau also deswegen,
tut lob auch immer gut aber ich glaube wir haben auch so das gefühl wir machen das auch weil's einfach ein unfassbar schöner beruf ist das machen.
Trotzdem werdet ihr auch auf dem kongress dieses jahr wieder sein.
Also das wäre auf jeden fall ein ein ort wo man in euch hinein laufen kann wenn man so,
gucken kann was man so mit seinen skills vielleicht noch beitragen kann also der quelle scheint ja hier auf jeden fall gegeben zu sein.
Bleib mir eigentlich nur noch zu sagen vielen dank für eure arbeit natürlich aber auch hier fürs gespräch,
du noch etwas beizutragen.
Danke und ähm ja wie gesagt dass der spenden formular ist wirklich sehr elegant.
Tief bedienbar.
Also sache von minuten hier.
Gar sekunden wenn man schnell mit der maus ist.
Ja
Ganz großen dank euch nochmal für die möglichkeit genau die sachen zu erzählen und reichweite zu schaffen das hilft uns total.
Und herzliche grüße an alle von carlos.
Das werde ich ausrichten jo ciao.
Ja dann verabschieden wir uns auch von unseren hörerinnen und hörern vielen dank fürs zuhören war heute mal etwas andere sendung aber muss ja auch mal sein ne und nächste woche geht's dann wieder weiter mit dem ganzen historischen digital kram.
Bis dann tschüss.